Astronomers following asteroid activity in space estimate there is a very small chance an object large enough to destroy a whole city could strike Earth in 2032.
跟踪太空中小行星活动的天文学家估计，一个足以摧毁整座城市的物体在2032年撞击地球的可能性非常小。
But space agency officials say even if such an asteroid keeps heading on a path toward Earth, the world is now much better-equipped to defend itself against such a threat.
但航天局官员表示，即使这样的小行星继续沿着朝向地球的路径前进，世界现在也更有能力防御此类威胁。
The American space agency NASA recently estimated there was a 3.1 percent chance that asteroid 2024 YR4 would hit Earth on December 22, 2032.
美国航天局NASA最近估计，小行星2024 YR4在2032年12月22日撞击地球的可能性为3.1%。
That is the highest probability predicted for such a large space rock in modern times.
这是现代对如此大的太空岩石预测的最高概率。
Richard Moissl is head of the European Space Agency's (ESA) planetary defense office.
理查德·莫伊塞尔是欧洲航天局（ESA）行星防御办公室的负责人。
While recognizing the risk the asteroid could present, he told the French news agency AFP people should not panic over such predictions.
在承认小行星可能带来的风险的同时，他告诉法国新闻机构法新社，人们不应因这类预测而恐慌。
Astronomers have noted that the more data they gather, the odds of a direct asteroid hit are expected to keep rising over time.
天文学家指出，他们收集的数据越多，小行星直接撞击的几率预计会随时间持续上升。
However, scientists say at a certain point the odds will likely drop down to zero.
然而，科学家表示，在某个节点，几率可能会降至零。
Moissl said he thinks it is important to remember that even in the unlikely event the probability keeps rising to 100 percent, the world is "not defenseless."
莫伊塞尔说，他认为重要的是要记住，即使在不太可能的情况下概率持续上升至100%，世界也“并非毫无防御能力”。
Here are some methods currently being considered as defensive measures to keep humanity safe in case there is a real threat.
以下是一些目前正在考虑的防御措施，以在出现真实威胁时确保人类安全。
Only one planetary defense method has been tried against an asteroid.
只有一种行星防御方法曾在小行星上尝试过。
In 2022, NASA's Double Asteroid Redirection Test (DART) sent a spacecraft into the 160-meter-wide Dimorphos asteroid.
2022年，NASA的双小行星重定向测试（DART）将一艘航天器送入宽160米的迪莫弗斯小行星。
The effort successfully changed the asteroid's orbit around a larger space rock.
这次行动成功改变了该小行星围绕一颗更大太空岩石的轨道。
Bruce Betts is chief scientist for the nonprofit Planetary Society.
布鲁斯·贝茨是非营利组织行星学会的首席科学家。
He told AFP that space agencies could hit the 2024 YR4 asteroid with several spacecrafts, observing how each one changed the path.
他告诉法新社，航天机构可以用多艘航天器撞击2024 YR4小行星，观察每一艘如何改变其路径。
The asteroid discovered in December is estimated to be 40-90 meters wide -- about half the size of Dimorphos.
去年12月发现的这颗小行星估计宽40-90米，大约是迪莫弗斯大小的一半。
"You have to take care not to overdo it," Moissl warned.
“必须小心不要过度，”莫伊塞尔警告说。
He said this is because if a spacecraft only partly destroys an asteroid, it could send smaller pieces of the space rock heading toward Earth.
他说，这是因为如果航天器只部分摧毁小行星，可能会将更小的碎片推向地球。
A separate idea would involve sending a large spacecraft to fly alongside a threatening asteroid.
另一个想法涉及发射一艘大型航天器与有威胁的小行星并排飞行。
The spacecraft would not touch the asteroid, but would use its gravitational force to pull it away from Earth.
航天器不会接触小行星，而是利用其引力将其拉离地球。
Moissl said another non-contact plan would put a spacecraft near the asteroid to eject a continuous flow of atoms to push the asteroid off course.
莫伊塞尔说，另一个非接触式计划是将航天器放置在小行星附近，持续喷射原子流，将小行星推离轨道。
Scientists have also considered painting one side of the asteroid white.
科学家还考虑将小行星的一侧涂成白色。
They believe this could increase the light the object reflects to make it slowly change course.
他们相信这可以增加该物体反射的光线，使其缓慢改变方向。
One idea is to use a nuclear weapon against a threatening asteroid.
一个想法是使用核武器对付有威胁的小行星。
In laboratory tests, researchers found that X-rays from a nuclear blast could move a rock.
在实验室测试中，研究人员发现核爆炸产生的X射线可以移动岩石。
But this is considered more of a plan for kilometers-wide asteroids like the one that killed off the dinosaurs.
但这更多地被视为针对像灭绝恐龙那样宽达数公里的小行星的计划。
And this method also carries the risk that a nuclear explosion could send additional pieces of the asteroid falling toward Earth.
而且这种方法还带有风险：核爆炸可能导致更多小行星碎片落向地球。
A similar method - but one considered less dangerous - would involve shooting laser beams from a spacecraft to destroy the side of an asteroid in an effort to push it away from Earth.
一种类似但被认为危险较小的方法，涉及从航天器发射激光束摧毁小行星的一侧，以将其推离地球。
Moissl said that if all else fails, at least the world will have a good idea where a threatening asteroid would strike.
莫伊塞尔说，如果其他方法都失败，至少世界将很清楚有威胁的小行星会在哪里撞击。
Since astronomers believe most asteroids would at most threaten to destroy one city, efforts could be organized to get people out of an area before a strike.
由于天文学家认为大多数小行星最多威胁摧毁一座城市，可以在撞击前组织人们撤离该区域。
"Seven-and-a-half years is a long time to prepare," Moissl added.
“七年半的时间足够准备，”莫伊塞尔补充道。
He also noted that even with the rising odds involving 2024 YR4, there is still about a 97 percent chance the asteroid will miss Earth.
他还指出，即使2024 YR4的几率上升，该小行星仍有约97%的可能性会错过地球。
I'm Jill Robbins.
我是吉尔·罗宾斯。